ok another chapter a little heavy
which economic policy within the European framework
basically to start in the intro we can say that
European integration
is the result of a desire to create lasting peace
in a europe
bruised by numerous world conflicts
so the first part
it is the stages of European integration
so there the first part
so in fact it is necessary to know that after the blow
major events
that have bruised the whole world
like the great depression in the first world war
the Second World War
all economic crises etc.
after these great bruised events
the economists responsible for
a little bit of getting the economy back on track etc.
who are also called the founding fathers
so they decide to strengthen the cooperation
between states
and as a result
the question that all economists were asking themselves
is how you can recreate an economy
by making peace
something effective and at the center of everything
and then this is where she was born
the idea of between countries
basically the idea was that
if all countries were dependent on each other
for their supply chain
for their raw materials etc.
from then on they could no longer wage war on each other
basically for example
if germany needed i say anything
French steel to make their car
from the moment there was an addiction
between the two countries
of their market
well they couldn't go to war anymore
and this is where the peace would have been maintained
then we can say that it's not too relevant anymore
because for example with the war in ukraine
russia it
it is
really well integrated in all its exchanges and
its interdependencies etc.
yet
it didn't stop him from waging war on the ukraine
so it all starts in 1951 with the ceca
which is a treaty establishing the European community
coal and steel
and basically it's the treaty that lays the foundations
of European integration
and it is recalled that the European process
it is a process leading to cohesion
economic and political
growing between European countries
then in 1957
it follows the signing of the Treaty of Rome
which promotes European economic integration
so then in this treaty of Rome there we have
cee is the european economic community
and it is a customs union
in quotation marks and-a common market
really apart
it is from July 1,
that the customs union is established
and it removes
any impediment to the circulation of banknotes
basically there are more borders for the products
products can go from one country to another
without paying taxes
finally they can go there much more simply
and then we have the common market or the single market
which provides for the free movement of property
as I come
to say it but not that also the services
capital and people for example
and for the free movement of persons
we can give for example the example of erasmus
which today authorizes students to
Europeans to go and learn
to go and study
in all member countries of the European Union
and then to finish
it is important to know that the euro zone
it is totally different from the European Union
the euro zone is the geographical whole
made up of the 19 countries of the European Union
who have adopted the euro as their national currency
while the European Union
it is a political and economic alliance
gathering 27 European countries part 2